japan's former prime minister shinzo abe
has died after being shot
during a campaign speech in the city of
nara in western japan joining me from
tokyo is koichiro matsumuto deputy
cabinet secretary for public affairs at
japan's prime minister's office hello
there thank you very much indeed for
your time today and what be must be an
incredibly uh difficult day just if you
wouldn't mind bringing us up to date
with developments what what happened and
where this was
on the campaign trail for elections this
weekend wasn't it
indeed uh you heard from prime minister
kishida just now uh well uh prime
minister krishna came back from his
electoral campaign uh early in the
afternoon he was praying for the
recovery hoping that prime minister abe
would somehow recover he was shot
by a man
in
manara prefecture which is
in the western part of japan close to
osaka and kyoto
and uh at
1703 three minutes after 5pm uh former
prime minister abe
passed away and this was confirmed
by the hospital and
by the doctors and the prime minister
kishima himself uh yeah that's where we
are now
and it must be a terrible shock to the
governments
and the country as a whole
exactly uh
we are we are feeling the uh
excruciating pain and uh
uh prime minister kishida expressed uh
uh
uh
that he's terribly sorry for the laws of
this great uh statesman and he also said
he's speechless
and he wishes that prime minister this
whole
rest in peace
and when people think about japan and
government and politics that is one man
that stands out really he's one name
that people will remember given the fact
that he was perhaps in office for so
long the longest serving prime minister
there
yes nick uh he was a longest-serving
prime minister in
japanese history
and one of the most prominent leader
of our time not only in japan but also
around the world among where he met he
was held in high
regard for
his
deep commitment to diplomacy economy and
national security and he was strong
believer in japan and he helped
his nation
recover
economically through his policy package
called the abenomics
and this sold the seats for the economic
recovery that we are enjoying now and
also
he was very much eager to upgrade
japan's
defense capability
and security legislation
and also he was also champion for gender
equality
putting in place
corporate governance codes
diversity in japan
and that means that he was really well
regarded as some kind of
not revolutionary but really wanted to
bring japan forward
precisely at 67 year old
he was still very much determined to
serve the country he loved he dearly
loved
and mr abe
as you know served for two times as
prime minister
between 2006 and seven and the second
time uh 2012 and 2020. so he's
always remembered uh dearly by the
japanese people as the longest serving
prime minister of japanese history and
he is such a kind person
and it was only that he left office
because of this recurring health problem
that he that he'd had
otherwise he'd still be there no doubt
uh well i i i would um heard from that
comment on that but uh uh let's just say
that he was uh remember he will be
remembered as a great statesman
and uh very uh
uh he instilled in the love for the
country
indeed and
tell us about the gun control the gun
laws because this is something that's
very very rare to happen in japan and
that is perhaps why the country is more
shocked today than
it might have been that somebody was
able to make what looks like an
improvised homemade device of this type
yes we are not yet certain about
the picture the big picture of
or the background of this entire crime
so i will not uh comment on that uh
with some definitiveness but uh you're
quite right uh japan is quite famous for
the very strict gun control any position
or
acquisition of guns as such
without the permit is illegal
and what happens now in such
circumstances this is unheard of you
won't have gone through this
will you but is there some kind of
period of of mourning now for the uh
former prime minister what happens what
was the protocol
uh well um prime minister made it very
clear that
we're now in the middle of our election
campaign election period uh but he
said that
he he will conduct the election as
planned uh we will not give in to this
terrible violence uh which may shake the
very foundation of democracy but we will
not give in to it and he was very stern
uh and he was saying that we will
continue the election campaign as
planned
all right well i once again do
appreciate your time on what is an
incredibly uh difficult day uh thank you
for coming on to the program and uh
remembering uh mr abbey for us thank you
thank you very much